Selamlar, sevgiler. Kanalıma hoş
geldiniz. 36 günde Türkçe kampının
geldik 7. gününe. Bugün konusu sıfatlar.
Sıfatları harika bir şekilde
bitireceğiz. Hemen şu kamp kitabımızdan
sayfa 36'yı açıyorum. Sıfatlar bir diğer
adıyla, Türkçe adıyla daha doğrusu ön ad
karşımızda.
Evet efendim bugünkü konumuz sıfatlar.
Mükemmel bir şekilde tüm uyarılarımızda
ince noktalarıyla bitireceğiz ve
devamında yarın yani 8. gün yine bu
kitaptan 5 tane soruyu çözeceğiz. Şu
kitaptan da 12 13 tane soruyu çözüp
sıfatlar konusunu çok iyi bir şekilde
pekiştirmiş olacağız. Şimdi derse
başlayacağız ama öncesinde bir ricam
var. Lütfen bu videoyu beğen, kanalıma
abone ol ve arkadaşlarınla paylaşmayı
unutma. Şimdi şöyle sıfatlar gelsin. Bir
diğer adı sıfatların ön hatlardır. Sıfat
Arapça ismidir. Bu bilgiyi alın. Devam
edelim. İsimlerden önce gelerek onları
sayı, renk, durum, hareket, biçim, yer,
işaret ve soru yönlerinden tamamlayan,
onları niteleyen ya da belirten kelime
ve kelime gruplarına sıfat denir. Yani
demek ki birinci özelliğimiz şu
isimlerden önce geliyor. Onları sayı,
renk, durum, hareket, biçim, yer,
işaret, soru yönünden tamamlayan ya da
onların özelliğini gösteren sözcüklere
biz sıfat diyoruz. Şimdi sıfatların bazı
özellikleri var. Mesela onlardan bir
tanesi şu sıfatlar genellikle isimlerden
önce gelir. Bak ön at diyorduk. İsmi
neydi? Türkçe adı ön at. İsimlerden önce
gelir genellikle. Şimdi gelmeyen
örnekler var. Onlara atlaşmış sıfat
diyeceğiz. İstisnalar var. Birazdan
göreceğiz zaten. Ve sıfatlar genellikle
çekmeklerini almazlar. Mesela güzel
araba. Bak güzel burada sıfattır. Şimdi
sen buna ek getir. Güzeli araba, güzel
de araba, güzele araba, güzeller araba
olmuyor. Yani çekim ekinin büyük bir
oranda olmadığını söyleyebiliriz
sıfatlar için ama istisnalar var. Mesela
güzelim araba dedik. Bak ne oldu? Oldu.
Nasıl araba? güzelim araba. Yani nadiren
de olsa istisna olarak çekim eki
alabilen örnekleri de söz konusu ve
bununla birlikte sıfatlar tek başlarına
bulunmazlar. Yine istisnalar var
altlaşma sıfatlarda bu ama genel bir
kuraldır. Şimdi burada sıfatların genel
özelliklerine değindik. Gel şimdi bir de
sıfat çeşitlerine bakalım. Şimdi neleri
göreceğiz? Öncelikle sıfatı iki ana
çatıda inceliyoruz. Bunların birincisi
niteleme sıfatı, ikincisi ise belirtme
sıfatı. Niteleme özelliğini gösteren
isimlerin belirtme ise isimlerin işaret
yoluyla gösterildiği işte beli belirsiz
olarak ifade edildiği, sayı olarak ifade
edildiği soru yoluyla ifade edildiği
sıfatlardır. Bir de bunların dışında
atlaşmış pekiştirme sıfatları ve unvan
sıfatlarını da ayrıca göreceğiz. Dop
dolu bir ders başlıyor. Hadi gel şimdi
niteleme sıfatlarıyla başlayalım.
Niteleme nedir? nitelikten gelir.
Nitelik özellik demektir. Yani niteleme
sıfatı aslında isimlerin özelliklerini
gösteren sıfatlardır. Bak isimleri
durum, biçim, renk ve unvanlarıyla
bildiren sıfatlara biz niteleme sıfatı
diyoruz. Ve isme nasıl sorusunu
sorduğunuz zaman eğer cevap
alabiliyorsanız o niteleme sıfatıdır.
Mesela kalem. Nasıl kalem? Kırmızı
kalem. Bak kalemin özelliğini gösterdi.
Nasıl yol? Dolanbaşlı yol. Nasıl silgi?
Yuvarlak silgi. Nasıl tahtta? Akıllı
tahtta. bak özelliklerini gösteriyor
ismin. Dolayısıyla bunlar unutma
niteleme sıfatıdır. Şimdi niteleme
sıfatının altında ele aldığımız bir
başka sıfat daha var. O da pekiştirme.
Yani niteleme sıfatlarının anlamca
güçlendirilmesiyle oluşan sıfatlara
pekiştirme sıfatı denir. İki farklı
şekilde yapılabilir. Bunların birincisi
şu ilk sözcüğün ilk önlüsüne kadar olan
bölüm alınır. Oraya M, P, R, S ünsüleri
getirilir. Bu şekilde bir pekiştirme
yapılabilir. Mesela mavi aldın. MA'sını
ilk hecesini aldım. Mavinin mavi bu ya.
İlk hecesini aldın ma. Bir de araya şu
harflerden bir tanesini katarsın. Mesela
mas mavi deniz. Bak deniz mavi deniz
demek farklı bir şey. Mas mavi deniz
demek bambaşka bir şey. Yani mavi deniz
dediğin zaman sadece mavi olduğunu ifade
edersin ama mas mavi deniz, yemyeşil
deniz dediğin zaman onun renginin
abartılı olduğunu ifade edersin. Yalnız
adam dersin, tamam ifade eder ama yapa
yalnız dersen çok yalnız olduğu ifade
edilir. Park ama yemyeşil park bak
yemyeşil şeklinde olabilir. Bununla
birlikte pekiştirmenin ikinci yöntemi
ise sıfatların tekrar etmesidir. Mesela
bitki çeşit bitkiler demek tamam ama
çeşit çeşit bitkiler dersen daha da
pekiştirmiş oluyorsun. Zor sorular
demek. Soruların zor olduğunu gösterir
ama ya zor mu? Zor sorular kardeşim. Bu
nasıl sorulardı ya? Mahvolduk bittik
işte. 2025 TYT Türkçede dememek adına
dikkatlice dinliyorsun. Burada da ne
yapmış oluyorsun? Daha da pekiştirmiş
oluyorsun. İşte bu şekilde de
yapılabilir pekiştirme sıfatları. Şimdi
bir uyarımız var. Sakın ha pekiştirmeyi
gördüğün zaman niteleme sıfatı diye
atlama ya da pekiştirme sıfatı diye
atlama. Çünkü kullanıldığı yer çok
önemli. Ne demiştik? Sıfatlar bir ismin
önüne gelmeli. Ön at diyoruz zaten. Bak
ismi ön at. Türkçe ismi. Dolayısıyla
mesela mas mavi gözleri bana döndü
dediği zaman evet mas mavi gözler. Nasıl
gözler? Mas mavi gözler. Ancak şöyle
dersem mas mavi görünüyordu. Peki önünde
isim var mı? Hayır önünde isim yok.
Nasıl görünüyordu? Mas mavi bu zarf
olur. Bak bu zarf olur. Bambaşka bir
şey. Sakın ha bu kafanı karıştırmasın.
Tuzaklara düşme. Bununla birlikte
atlaşma sıfatlar var. O da niteleme
sıfatının bir alt başlığı olarak kabul
görmektedir. Burada da şunu unutma.
Niteleme sıfatları bazen çekim eki
alarak bazen de almayarak niteledikleri
ismi karşılayacak şekilde
kullanılabilir. Mesela düşünsenize hasta
adam dedim. Tamam mı? Şimdi adamı
silelim buradan. Nasıl adam? Hasta adam.
Tamam. Buraya kadar problem yok. Peki
adamı sildim. Şimdi hasta tek başına
kalsın. Şimdi hasta bir isim midir?
Hayır. Hasta bir özelliktir. Yani adamın
sağlık olarak iyi olmadığını ya da o
kadının yani insanın diyelim iyi
olmadığını sağlık açısından ifade eden
bir kelimedir. Dolayısıyla aslında hasta
bir sıfattır. Dolayısıyla sen bunu
kullandın ve önünde isim yoksa aslında
bu bir adlaşmış sıfattır. Bu mantık
aklında kalsın. Mesela yaşlı insanlar
çok duygusal olur diyoruz. Tamam. Nasıl
insanlar? Yaşlı insanlar. Bu niteleme
sıfatı mı? Evet. Şimdi ben insanları
kullanmasam şöyle desem yaşlılar çok
duygusal olur ya da yaşlı oradan bana el
sağladı vesaire. Bak oradaki yaşlı zaten
sıfat bir şeyin özelliğini gösteriyor.
Niteliğini gösteriyor. Dolayısıyla eğer
önünde ismi yoksa biz bunları atlaşmış
sıfat olarak almak durumundayız.
Yaşlılar çok duygusal olur dersen de
atlaşmış sıfattır. Ya da az önce
verdiğim gibi örnek işte yaşlı oradan
bana gülümseyerek el salladı. Buradaki
yaşlı da bir sıfattır. E ama önde isim
yok. Dolayısıyla atlaşma sıfat olarak
kabul görmektedir. Yani illa şunlar
ekinin olmasına gerek yok. Çalışkan
öğrenciler kütüphaneden çıkmıyor. Tamam.
Nasıl öğrenciler? Çalışkan öğrenciler.
Ama şöyle de diyebiliriz. Çalışkanlar
kütüphaneden çıkmıyor. Bak çalışkanlar
sonuçta çalışkanlık bir sıfattır. İsim
değildir. Çalışkan. Çünkü bir şeyin
özelliğini göstermek için kullanılan bir
kelimedir. Sözcüktür. Dolayısıyla o da
unutma atlaşmış sıfat olur. Eğer önde
isim yoksa. Evet. Şimdi atlaşmış sıfatın
mantığı da bu. Sorularda ne demek
istediğimi daha net anlayacaksın. Şimdi
bir de küçültme sıfatına bakalım. Sıfat
olan sözcüklere c, cik, imtrak, imsi
eklerini getirirseniz biz bunlara artık
küçültme sıfatı deriz. Yani burada
aslında şunu e sağlamayı amaçlarız.
Mesela düşünsenize koltuk büyük koltuk
dersem tamam büyük koltuk gerçekten bu
koltuk büyük anlamı çıkar. Ama büyükçe
koltuk dersem şöyle demek istiyorum
aslında. Yani koltuk büyüğe yakın
anlamında. Tam büyük değil yani büyük
gibi. Mesela küçücük bahçe ne yapıyorum?
Daha da küçültmüş oluyorum. Yani küçük
ama küçücük dersem daha da küçültmüş
oluyorum. Ekşimsi yoğurt. Yani böyle
ekşi yakın. O anlamda zaten küçültme
mantığını veriyoruz. Tamam mı? Yani tam
olarak ekşi değil zaten. Ekşi olsa ekşi
diyeceğiz. Ama ekşimsi dediğimiz zaman o
yoğurdun ekşe yakın olduğunu ifade
ediyorum. İşte yeşilim trak bir halı.
Yani tam yeşil gibi değil yakın gibi.
Güzelce bir ev yani. Yani güzel değil
ama güzele yakın gibi bir anlam var.
İşte minicik araba. Burada da küçültmüş
oluyorsun. Bizzat küçültüyorsun zaten.
Yani araba minik araba dersen tamam
küçük araba ama minik yüklersen daha da
küçültmüş oluyorsun. Küçültme sıfatları
da bunlardı. Karşıma çıkar mı? Çıkabilir
bence. Belirtme sıfatlarına gelelim.
Şimdi iki ana başta ayırmıştık.
Birincisi niteleme, ikincisi belirtme
sıfatları. Şimdi gel belirtme
sıfatlarına yakından bakalım. O da kendi
içerisinde dörde ayrılır. Sayı sıfatı,
işaret sıfatı, belgesi sıfat ve soru
sıfatı olmak üzere hemen sayı sıfatıyla
başlayalım. sayı isimlerin önüne gelerek
onların çeşitli açıdan sayısını,
sırasını, kaçar kaçar bölündüğünü ya da
oranını gösteren sıfatlardır. İşte bu
saydığım özelliklere göre de kendi
içerisinde 4 hatta 5'e ayrılır. Nasıl?
Şimdi bak bir tanesi asıl sayı sıfatı
ismin önüne gelir. O isimden kaç tane o
varlıktan kaç tane olduğunu gösterir.
Mesela 3 saat sonra gelecekti. Peki saat
kaç saat? Bu arada kaç sorusunu
kullanırım? Eğer isme kaç sorusunu
sorarsan cevap alırsan bu ne olur? Bu
sayı sıfatı olur. Asıl sayı sıfatı olur.
Peki 5 arkadaşıyla kaç arkadaşı? 5
arkadaşı. Bak bunlar kaç kişiler? 5.
Yani 5 tane arkadaşın olduğunu ifade
ediyor. Bunlar asıl sayı sıfatıdır.
Şimdi bununla birlikte tek sözcüğü ve
çift sözcüğü bunun üzerinde de durmak
gerekiyor. Çünkü tek, çift bunlar
kafamızı karıştırmak adına denemelerde,
testlerde karşımıza çıkıyor. Şimdi
düşünsenize ben mesela şöyle bir örnek
verdim. Tek kişilik bilet aldı. Aslında
ne demek istiyorum? Tek kişilik derken
bir kişilik bilet aldı. Bak bir kişilik
bu anlam var. Dolayısıyla tek de asıl
sayı sıfatıdır. Bununla birlikte mesela
çift kişilik odamız yok. Yani çift
kişilikten kastımız ne? 2 kişilik odamız
yok. Şimdi çiftin yerine 2'yi
kullanabilir miyim? Kullanabilirim. Çift
aslında burada 2 anlamda kullanılmıştır.
Dolayısıyla bu da asıl sayı sıfatıdır.
Bu çok ince bir ayrıntı. Şimdi gelelim
sıra sayı sıfatına. Bu da isimlerin
sırasını, derecesini gösteren sayı
sıfatlarıdır. Ve kaçıncı sorusuna cevap
verir? Bak dikkat et. Kitabın 5.
sayfasında bu konudan bahsedilmiş. Peki
kaçıncı sayfasında? Soruyu sordum. 5.
sayfasında sıra olarak yerini gösterdi.
Sayısını gösterdi. 1 2 3 4 değil 5.
sayfada şeklinde. Bu da sıra sayı
sıfatıdır. Şimdi bununla birlikte nasıl
ki az önce tek ve çifte odaklandık.
Burada da ilk ve son sözcüklere
odaklanacağız. Eğer bunlar bir ismin öne
gelirse ilk ve son bunların da sıra sayı
sıfatı olduğunu unutma. Çünkü yarışmada
sonuncu aday oldu dersem sırasını
gösteriyor. Bak sonuncu aday sırasını
gösteriyor. İlk aday dersem birinci kişi
olduğunu ifade eder. Ama burada unutma
mesela sınavda şöyle bir örnek
kullansam. Sınavda birinci oldu. Şimdi L
çıkmadı. Oldu diyelim. Kaçıncı oldu?
Birinci. Bak olduya soruyorum. Yükleme
soruyorum. Bu kesinlikle sıfat olmaz.
Sıfat olması için 5. sayfası sonuncu
aday, sınavda 1inci öğrenci şeklinde
önünde ismin olması gerekiyor. Buna da
dikkat et. Şimdi üleştirme sıfatına
bakalım. Varlıkların ayrıldığı eşit
bölümleri anlatan sıfatlardır ve kaçar
sorusuna cevap verir. Mesela bu sınavda
sıfat ve zamir konusundan altışar soru
çıkacak. Kaçar. Bak ismi buldum. İsim bu
ya. Kaçar sorusunu sordum. Kaçar?
Altışar cevabını bana verdi ve bununla
birlikte yazım kuralı bilgisi üleştirme
sayıları mutlaka yazıyla gösterilmeli.
Yani sen sınavda beşer şeklinde bir
örnek görürsen bu yazım yanlıştır.
Unutma üleştirmeler kesinlikle yazıyla
gösterilmeli. Bu bir yazım kuralıdır.
Bunu da ek bilgi olarak buraya ekledim.
Tabii ki yazım kurallarını anlatacağım
ama burada da aklınızda kalsın. Kesir
sayı sıfatlarına gelelim. Bu da ismin
belli bir oranını, bütünün bir parçasını
gösteren sıfatlardır. Mesela bu sınavda
sınıf %70 başarı gösterdi. Bak başarının
yüzde kaçı? %75'i. Yani 100 tane var.
Bunun 75 tanesini aldım. Belli bir
oranını gösterdi. Ya da çeyrek altın
dedim. Bu aralar çok pahalı olduğu için
artık pek ağzımızdan çıkmıyor. Ancak
konuşuyoruz, alamıyoruz. Neyse çeyrek
altın. Şimdi tam altın var. Bir de tam
altın da bu arada kesir sayı sıfatıdır.
Şimdi bak düşün. tam altın bütünü ifade
eder. Çeyrek altın ise bunun 14te birini
ifade eder. Değil mi? Dolayısıyla bu
kesir sayı sıfatıdır. İşte bu da böyle.
Ama önünde isim olması lazım. Mesela
çeyrek dersem önünde bir isim yoksa e o
sıfat olmaz unutma. Şimdi bir de
topluluk sayı sıfatından bahsetmek
istiyorum. Birbirinin aynı olan birden
fazla varlığı tanımlamak için kullanılan
ve rakamların sonuna iz ekinin
getirilmesiyle oluşturulan sıfatlara
topluluk sayı sıfatı denir. Mesela ikiz
yatak. Bak ikiz yatak aynı olduğunu
ifade ediyor. Üç kardeşler bu
kardeşlerin aynı olduğunu ifade ediyor.
Bu şekilde bir kullanım karşına çıkarsa
bu da topluluk sayı sıfatıdır. Az önce
yapmış olduğum bir uyarı tekrar
karşımıza çıktı. Sayı sıfatlarının
önünde de mutlaka bir isim olması
gerekiyor. Yani tüm sıfatlarda olduğu
gibi burada da sayı sıfatlarının önünde
bir isim olması gerekiyor. Mesela
yarışmada 5 oldu. Bak bu isimdir. Neden?
Çünkü önünde isim yok. Ama 5 öğrenci
oldu dersem sıfattır. Neden? Çünkü
önünde isim var. Kaçıncı öğrenci? 5.
öğrenci. Peki kaçıncı oldu? 5 yani file
sorduğum sorunun cevabı sıfat olamaz. Bu
tekrar önemli olduğu için karşımıza
çıktı. Şimdi bir de işaret sıfatına
bakalım. O da varlıkların nesnelerinin
yerini işaret yoluyla gösteren
sıfatlardır. Bu, şu, o böyle, öyle,
şöyle, öteki beriki, öte beri diğer işte
bunlar en çok kullanılan işaret
sıfatlarıdır. Hangi sorusuna cevap
verir? Ve unutma önünde ne olması
gerekiyor? İsmin olması gerekiyor. Eğer
önünde ismi yoksa o işaret sıfatı
olamaz. Mesela bu massanın hangi masa?
Bu masa. Hangi çocuk? Öteki çocuk. Hangi
ev? Öbür ev. İşte böylesini bu takım hak
etmedi. Bak böylesini. Önde isim var mı?
Böylesini yok. Ama şöyle dese böyle
sonucu deseydi bu ne olacaktı? İşaret
sıfatı olacaktı. Çünkü önünde isim var.
Hangi sonuç? Böyle sonuç. Ama böylesin
diyor. Önde isim yok. Bu ne olur biliyor
musunuz? Daha sonra işleyeceğiz. Zamir
olur. Zamir unutma. İşaret zamir olur.
Ama bu takım hak etmedi derken bu dikkat
et hangi takım? Bu takım şeklinde bu
işaret sıfatı olur. Şimdi bir sınav
alarmı var. Çok çok önemli. O sözcüğü
bir ismin yerine geçiyorsa zamir, ismi
gösteriyorsa sıfat olur. Mesela o adamı
uzun süre takip etmişti. Kim o? Bir
insan ismin yerine kullanılmış. Bu şahs
zamiri. Ama o adamı uzun süre takip
etmişti dersem dolayısıyla gördüğünüz
gibi adamı gösteriyor. Dolayısıyla bu ne
olur? işaret sıfatı olur. Bir de bunun
dışında bu şu o zamirleri özne olarak
kullanıldığında unutma kendisinden önce
bir virgül gelmedi. Çünkü virgül
gelmezse karışıyor. Bak hatta sileyim
tekrar göstereyim şurayı. Bak burada
virgül var. Burada virgül yok. Şimdi
anlam karışıyor. O adam mı yoksa o adamı
mı? Anlam karışıyor. O yüzden ne olması
gerekiyor? Kesinlikle eğer bunlar
zamirse kendisinden sonra virgülün
olması gerekiyor. Ki bunu da ÖSM daha
önce sordu. Yazım kurallarında. Bak aynı
zamanda yazım kurallarını da bitirmiş
oluyoruz. Devam edelim. Belgesel
sıfatlara geldik. Varlıkları, kavramları
onlara kesinlik kazandırmadan yani aşağı
yukarı belirten sıfatlara belgesiz sıfat
denir. Bir, birkaç, çok, birçok, bazı,
tüm, her, bütün, hiçbir, herhangi bir,
kimi, birtım gibi sıfatlar belgesi
sıfattır. Ama bunlar çok çok önemli
unutma. İsmin önüne gelmeli. Çünkü ismin
önüne gelmediği zaman zamirleşiyorlar.
Ek aldıkları zaman zamirleşiyorlar. Onu
söyleyeyim. Zamir konusunda zaten 9.
günde bunu anlatacağım. Şimdi tüm
öğrencilerini aldı. Bak öğrenciler isim
mi? İsim. Bazı insanlar insanlar isim
mi? Evet. Birçok soruyu soru isim mi?
Evet isim. Peki dikkat et. Hangi
öğrenciler? Bak yine hangi sorusunu
sorabilirim. Tüm öğrenciler. Ama bu
öğrenciler kaç kişi? Kimler? Ahmet,
Mehmet, Fatma, Ayşe belli değil. İşte o
yüzden bu belgesiz sıfattır. Bazı
insanlar iyi de hangi insanlar kaç kişi
belli değil? Belgisiz sıfat. Birçok
soru. İyi de kim? Kaç kişi belli değil.
O yüzden bu da belgesiz sıfat olacak.
Burada uyarımız var. Az önce söylediğim
şeyi tekrar karşınıza getirdim. Çoğu ve
kimi sözcükleri zamir olarak da
kullanabilir. Yani çoğunlukla mesela
bazı insanlar dersem bu tabii ki
belgesattır ama bazıları dersem
zamirleşir. Yani ek alırsa zamirleşir.
Tümü dersem zamirleşir. Birçoğu dersem
zamirleşir. Ama çoğu ve kimi sözcükleri
bu şekilde kullanılsa da zamir olarak da
karşımıza çıkabilir. Nasıl? Bakacaksın.
Önünde isim var mı yok mu? Mesela
öğrencilerin çoğu dedin. Bak bu örneğe
dikkat et. İyi de mesela çoğu şey önünde
isim var mı? Yok. Öğrencilerin çoğu
yeteri kadar ders çalışmadı. Çoğun
önünde bir isim yok. Gördün mü?
Dolayısıyla bu zamirdir. Ama çoğu
öğrenci. Hangi öğrenci? Çoğu öğrenci.
Bak önde isim var. O zaman sıfata
dönüşüyor. Aynı mantıkla. Mesela kimi
insan. Bak insan burada isimdir. Hangi
insan? Kimi insan. İsmi gösteriyor
belirsiz yönüyle. Bu belgesiz sıfattır.
Ama kimi arasam önde isim yok.
Dolayısıyla bu ne oldu? Belgisiz zamir
oldu. Bu da yine çok önemli bir
uyarıydı. Bitti mi? Hayır. Az önce de
söyledim. Belgiseliz sıfatlar ek
aldıklarında çoğu zaman belgisiz zamire
dönüşür. Mesela tüm öğrenciler örneğini
verdik az önce. At mesela öndeki ismi ve
buna ek getir. Tümü dedin. Ne oldu?
Belgisi zamir oldu. Ya hocam atlaşma
sıfat olmaz mı? O niteleme sıfatında
olur. Unutma. Atlaşma sıfat niteleme
sıfatında olur. Burada olmuyor. Burada
ne oluyor? Zamirleşiyor. Unutma. Bir
başka uyarımız bir sözcüğü ismin
önündeyse ve tek anlamında kullanılırsa
o zaman sayı sıfatı olur. Ancak yine
ismin önünde ve herhangi bir anlamda
kullanılırsa herhangi bir anlamda
kullanılırsa bak herhangi bir anlamında
daha doğrusu kullanılırsa o zaman
belgesiz sıfat olur. Mesela sınavda bir
soru yanlış yaptı. Tamam. Yerine mesela
2'yi 3'ü getirebilir miyim?
Getirebilirim. Sınavda 3 soruyu yanlış
yaptı. 4 soruyu yanlış yaptı. Bak
diyebiliyorum. Bu direkt sayı sıfatıdır.
Ancak şöyle dersem bir gün anlayacaksın.
Sessizce neden gittiğimi. Bunun şarkısı
vardı ya. Bir gün anlayacaksın
sessizce neden gittiğimizi.
[Müzik]
>> Kimindi ya? Lemans Samındı değil mi?
Neyse aklıma gelmedi. Şarkının bu kadarı
geldi. Şimdi bak bir gün anlayacaksın.
Şimdi ben bunun yerine iki gün
anlayacaksın neden gittiği. Olur mu?
Olmaz. Ben bir gün intikamım mı alacağım
arkadaşım? Ben iki gün intikamım mı
alacağım? Olur mu? Olmaz. Yani yerine
2'yi getiremiyoruz. İşte bu herhangi bir
anlamındadır. Yani bir gün öyle bir gün
gelecek ki anlayacaksın manası vardır.
İşte o yüzden belgisiz sıfattır. Unutma.
Şimdi yine bir uyarımız var. Eğer bir
sözcüğü aynı anlama gelecek şekilde
kullanırsa, bak bir aynı anlama gelecek
şekilde kullanırsa bu sefer de niteleme
sıfatı oluyor. Mesela onlarla bir safta
savaştık. Bak onlarla bir safta. Bir
safta yani aynı saf anlamı var. Hatta şu
örnekte de olmaz mı? Biz bir
takımdaydık. Onlar da bir takımdaydı.
Yani oradaki bir sayı anlamı değil. Yani
aynı takımdaydık, onlar da aynı
takımdaydı şeklinde. O anlamda
kullanılırsa bunu anlaman lazım. Ama
mesela bir safta bu net olarak ortaya
çıkıyor. Dolayısıyla bu da niteleme
sıfatı oluyor. Şimdi geldik soru
sıfatlarına. İsimleri soru yoluyla
gösteren sözcüklere biz soru sıfatı
diyoruz. Yani gördüğün gibi eğer işaret
yoluyla gösterirse işaret sıfatı, sayı
yönüyle gösterirse bu sayı sıfatı,
özelliğini gösterirse nitme sıfatı ama
soru yönüyle bir ismi gösteriyorsa o
zaman biz buna soru sıfatı diyoruz.
Genellikle hangi, nasıl, kaç, kaçıncı,
kaçan, ne kadar sıfatları karşımıza
çıkıyor soru sıfatlarında. Mesela hangi
arabayı aldın? Bak araba burada isim mi?
İsim. Şimdi soruyor. Hangi araba soru
yoluyla isme bir eee atıfta bulunuyor?
Dolayısıyla bu soru sıfatı. Cevap
verelim. Hangi arabayı aldın? Bu arabayı
aldım. Şimdi hangi sorusunu biz ne için
kullanıyorduk? Unutma, işaret sıfatını
bulmak için kullanıyorduk. Bak cevap da
ne olacaktır o zaman? Hangi sorusunun
işaret sıfatı olacaktır. Bu arabayı
aldım. Bu işaret ediyorum. Kaçıncı
bölümü bitirdin? Kaçıncı biz ne için
kullanıyorduk? Sıra sayı sıfatını bulmak
için kullanıyorduk. O zaman 5. bölümü
bitirdim. Bak ne oldu? 5 sıra sayı
sıfatı oldu. Gördün mü? Onu bulmak için
kullandığımız soru isme geliyorsa soru
sıfatı olur. Cevabı da zaten ne
olacaktır? Sıra sayı sıfatı olacaktır.
Bu işten kaçar lira kazandınız? Beşer
lira. Ne oldu? Üleştirme sıfatı oldu.
Gördün mü? E üleştirme sıfatı bulmak
için ne kullanıyorduk? Kaçarı
kullanıyorduk. Eğer isme gelirse. Tamam.
Araban ne renk? Bak ne sözcüğüne çok
dikkat et. Çünkü ne sıfat olabilir, zarf
olabilir, zamir olabilir. Eğer ismi
gösteriyorsa, evet burada da gördüğünüz
gibi sıfattır. Ama ismin yerine geçerse
zamirdir. Ama fiili gösterirse ya da bir
fiilimsi o zaman da zartlaşır. O yüzden
dikkat edeceksin. Ama burada ismi
gösteriyor. Ne renk? Bak rengi ismi
gösteriyor. Bununla birlikte bir
uyarımız var. Dikkat ediyorsun. İsme
getirilen soru sıfatlarının cevapları
çoğunlukla sıfat olmaktadır. Yukarıdaki
örneklerde de gördüğümüz üzere. Şimdi
devam edelim. Kurallı birleşik sıfata
gelelim. Daha önce sözcükte yapıda buna
değinmiştik. Burada da hızlı bir şekilde
gözden geçirelim. Şimdi birleşik
sıfatlar vardır ve bunlar içerisinde
kurallı sıfatlar soruluyor. Mesela sana
diyor ki vatansever
adam. Şimdi buradaki adam isimdir. Nasıl
adam çıkıyor mu? Çıkıyor. Vatansever.
Şimdi vatansever sıfat aslında niteleme
sıfatı ama birleşik bir sözcük olduğu
için bunu birleşik sıfat olarak da kabul
ediyorlar. Ama kurallı birleşik sıfat
farklıdır. Bak şöyle bir mantık var.
Mesela kırmızı başlık. Şimdi kırmızı
başlığı şuraya yazmak istiyorum. Kırmızı
başlık. Şimdi diyor ki sen bu ismin yani
bir sıfat tamlaması var burada. Kırmızı
başlık sıfat tamlamasıdır. Bu ismin
sonuna lı getir ya da lık getir ya da
siz getir ve bunun önüne bir tane daha
isim getir. Mesela kırmızı başlıklı
şimdi önüne bir isim gelmeli kız.
Gördüğün gibi artık kırmızı başlık ne
oldu? Sıfat ama kurallı birleşik sıfat.
Aynı şekilde geniş cadde lii dedim. Ön
bir isim getirmek zorundayım. Geniş
caddeli sokaklar dedim. Bak ne oldu?
Kurallı birleşik sıfat oldu. 3 asır
dedim. 3 asır bir sıfat tammıdır. Sonra
lık getirmişiz. 3 asırlık hikaye.
Gördüğün gibi işte bu kurallı birleşik
sıfatın birinci çeşidi. Bir de ikinci
çeşidi var. Orada da sıfat tamlamasıyla
sıfatla isim yer değiştiriyor ve isme
iyelik eki getiriliyor. Bu şekilde de
bir kurallı birileşik sıfat
oluşturuluyor. Nasıl? Hemen örnek
verelim. Mesela güzel diksiyon. Ne
yapıyorum? Diksiyon sola gitti. Güzel
sağda kaldı. E bir de buna iyelik ekini
getirecektim. Diksiyonu güzel. O zaman
U'yu getirdim. E bir de önüne mesela
diksiyonu güzel kadın dedim. Tamam mı?
Nasıl kadın? Diksiyonu güzel kadın.
Sonuçta kadınların diksiyonu erkeklere
göre çok daha iyi. Ben hep bunu tecrübe
ettim. Güzel bir örnek oldu. Aynı
şekilde kırık kanat ne yap? Yer
değiştir. Kanadı kırık de. Aynı zamanda
ı ekini getir. Sonra önüne bir tane de
isim getir. Kanadı kırık kuş. Ne oldu?
Kurallı bileşik sıfat oldu. İşte kurallı
bileşik sıfat budur. Unutma. Şimdi unvan
sıfatlarına son olarak bakalım. İnsan
isimlerine eklenen saygı ve tanıtma
sözcükleri unvan sıfatlardır. Mesela
öğretmen Kemal dedin. Kemal isim. Onun
mesleğini ifade ediyorsun. Öğretmen.
Direktör Ali Bey hem direktör hem de bey
nedir? Unvan sıfatıdır. Sultan Selim
buradaki sultan unvan sıfatıdır. Ve
unvan sıfatları ismin önüne de arkasına
gelebilir. Burada da gördüğünüz gibi
mesela B de sağa gelmiş. Direktör de
sola gelmiş. Bak buralarda ismin neyine
gelmiş? Sağına gelmiş. Deniz Hanım
örneği. Eskiden böyle kahve içmeye
giderdim. Bağırlardı. Deniz Hanım, Deniz
Hanım. Gelirdim derdim. O benim ay özür
dileriz falan derler ya da hala
arıyorlarmış hizmetlerinden. Deniz
hanımla görüşebilir miyiz diye.
Buyurunuz görüşebilirsiniz diyorum
vesaire.
>> Deniz Hanım
>> buyurunuz görüşebilirsiniz. Şimdi neyse
sıfat tamlamasına gelelim. Sıfat
tamamlamasını bilmekte fayda var ama
güzel haber şu ki sıfatı biliyorsan
sıfat tamamlamasını zaten biliyorsun.
Çünkü sıfat demek ne demektir? Hemen
örnek vermek istiyorum. Şurada not al
bölümümüz var. Güzel araba dedin ya.
Şimdi araba nedir burada? sıfattır. Daha
doğrusu güzel sıfattır. Araba ise burada
isimdir. Şimdi ikisi de aynı zamanda
neyi oluşturur biliyor musunuz? Sıfat
tamlamasını oluşturur. İsim tamlamasında
biz baştakine ne diyorduk? Tamlayan
diyorduk. Burada da aynı şekilde isme
ise burada yine tamlanan diyeceğiz.
Sırası değişmiyor. Yani yanan şeklinde
de yine tamlamalar geliyor gördüğünüz
gibi. Yani sıfatı biliyorsan orada zaten
bir sıfat tamlaması olduğunu
anlayabilirsin. Şimdi o yüzden diyoruz
ki sıfatın olduğu her yerde mutlaka bir
sıfat tamlaması vardır. Tamam. Sıfat
tamlaması için mutlaka bir isim ya da
onu niteleyen bir ya da belirten sıfatın
olması şarttır. Yani sıfat yoksa ismin
önünde zaten sıfat olmaz. Sıfat
tamlaması hiç olmaz. Sıfat tamasında
birinci sözcük yani sıfat tamlayan isim
ise tamlanandır. Az önce söylediğim gibi
mesela geniş sınıf. Nasıl sınıf? Geniş
sınıf. Geniş burada tamlayandır. Sınıf
ise burada tamlanandır. Tüm insanlar
burada tamlanan insanlar. Tüm ise burada
tamlayandır. Şu ağaç bak işaret ediyor.
İşaret sıfatı var. aynı zamanda bir isim
tamlamasıdır. Şimdi sıfatlar birden
fazla ismi belirtebilir, niteleyebilir.
Mesela çürümüş elmalar, armutlar,
muzlar. Bak tamlanan. Tamlanan tamlanan.
Peki nasıl elma, armut ve muzlar
çürümüş. Bu da tamlayan. Yani sıfatın
kendisi. Peki bir isme birden fazla
sıfat gelebilir mi? Gelebilir tabii ki.
Zeki, çalışkan, uslu, neşeli bir
çocuktu. Nasıl çocuk? Zeki, çalışkan,
uslu, neşeli. Çocuk burada tamlanan.
Bunlar ise burada tamlayan. Yani birden
fazla tamlayan var. Az önceki örneğin
tam tersi. Sıfatlar bir isim
tamlamasının önüne gelebilir. Bunu isim
tamlamasında bolca görmüştük. Unutulmaz
aşk acısı. Aşk acısı. Bak burada nedir?
Belirtisiz isim tamlaması. Nasıl
anlıyorduk? Hemen hatırlatmak istiyorum.
Aşk acı oluyor mu? Olmuyor. Olmuyorsa
demek ki bu sıfat tamlaması değil isim
tamlamasıdır. Ama mesela dikkat et
neşeli çocuk oluyor. O zaman sıfat
tamlaması. Yani eksiz oluyorsa bu sıfat
tamlaması. İlla iyelik ekine bağlıysa
anlam oluşturabilmesi için bu isim
tamlamasıdır. Şimdi bir de sıfat
çeşitlerine bakalım. Mesela niteleme
sıfatlarıyla oluşan nasıl hava? Yağmurlu
hava. Niteleme sıfatı. Nasıl gözler?
Mavi gözler. Niteleme sıfatı. Bunlar
nedir? Aynı zamanda sıfat tamlamasıdır.
İşaret sıfatıyla da oluşabilir. Yani tüm
sıfat çeşitleriyle aslında oluşur. Hangi
sorun? Bu sorun. Hangi soruyu? Öteki
soruyu. Bak işaret sıfatı. Bu da sıfat
tamamlamasıdır. Belgesi sıfatla
oluşabilir. Öğrenciler hangi öğrenciler?
Bazı öğrenciler, tüm insanlar. Gördüğün
gibi burada belki sıfat var. Aynı
zamanda sıfat ve isim sıfat tamlamasını
oluşturur. Soru sıfatıyla oluşanlara
bakalım. Kaç kitap kaçıncı sınıfta? Bak
ne yapıyor? Soru yoluyla bir sıfat
oluşmuş. Bunlar aynı zamanda sıfat
tamlamasıdır. Sayı sıfatıyla oluşabilir.
Beşer lira, 3 ekmek şeklinde ve sıfat
pillerle de oluşabilir. Sıfat pil ekleri
daha sonra işleyeceğiz. An, ası, mez,
ar, dik, ecek, miş ekleridir. Unutma.
Mesela gelecek günler. Günler burada
isimdir. Nasıl günler? Gelecek. Gelmek
fiiline ecek acak gelmiştir. Bu bir
sıfat fiilidir. Sıfat fiillerde niteleme
sıfatı olarak kabul görür. Sonuç
itibariyle gelecek günler burada bir
sıfat tamlamasıdır. Yüzündeki tükenmiş
ifade. Tükenmiş ifade. Bak tükenmekten
miş gelmiş. Anası mezar dikecekmiş
derken bu ek var zaten. Bu tükenmiş
sıfat bildir ama tükenmiş ifade aynı
zamanda sıfat tamlamasıdır. Toplantıya
sonradan gelen adam bak gelmekten gelen
olmuştur. Bu sıfat fiildir. Öndeki
isimdir. Bu ikisi de yine sıfat
tamlaması olur. Burada sıfat fiil
tamlayan olur. Hemen onu da gösterelim.
İsim ise tamlanan olur. Aynı mantıkla
devam ediyoruz. Evet arkadaşlar, şimdi
39'a kadar geldik. Sıfatları gördük.
39'dan sonra 40. sayfada ne var? Soru
tipleri var. Yani ÖSM nasıl soruyor?
Hatta ben de buradan açacağım. ÖSM nasıl
soruyor? Ya da kaynaklar nasıl soruyor
ya da denemelerde nasıl karşımıza
geliyor? Bunların hepsini burada soru
tipi olarak görüyorsunuz. Bunlar neden
önemli? Çünkü bunların hepsi karşına
çıkacak ya. Sen şimdiden bunlara hakim
ol ve tek cevaplana bak. Ben bunu
anlattım. Yani şöyle soru gelirse buna
odaklan. Şöyle gelirse buna odaklan.
Dolayısıyla sen tüm soru tiplerini
görmüş oluyorsun. Devamında da 1 2 3
sayfa etkinliğimiz var. Hemen göstermek
istiyorum. Sayfa 40'ta şu soru tipleri
vardı. Sayfa 41, 42 ve 43'te ise
etkinlikler var. Bu etkinlikleri sen
çözüyorsun. Şimdi bu videodan sonra
çözüyorsun. Çünkü db hep söylüyorum.
Konu olarak basit ama etkinlik olarak ya
da soru olarak bizi zorlar. Çünkü bir
sürü soru tipi var. Sen o soru tiplerine
neye odaklanman gerektiğini çok fazla
kavramayabilirsin. Ben de
zorlanabilirdim başta ama etkinlik
yaparak bu işi daha da böyle pekiştirme
yapma şansına sahip oluyoruz.
Dolayısıyla mutlaka bu soruları
yapabilmek için bu etkinlikleri
yapıyorsun ve devamında zaten aşağıda QR
bir kod var. Görüyorsunuz. Buradan
cevaplara ulaşabilirsin. Yani ne yaptın,
ne yapmadın hepsini oradan teyit
edeceksin. Ve yarınki dersimize yani 8.
günde sayfa 45'teki pardon düzeltiyorum
44'teki şu 5 soruyu çözeceğiz. Sonra
geleceğiz sayfa 53'e şu kitaba. O da
senin ödevin. Hemen ondan da bahsetmek
istiyorum. Sayfa 53'te test 2 var. Hemen
gelsin. 53'te test 2. Evet başladı ve
toplamda 12 sorumuz var. Evet sıfatlarla
ilgili test 2 çözüyorsun. Yarın 12 + 5
soruyu yani 17 soruyu birlikte çözeceğiz
ve konuyu pekiştemiş olacağız. O zaman
şimdilik benden bu kadar ama senden bir
isteğim var. Yardımına ihtiyacım var. 1
milyona doğru gidiyorum. Bu videoyu
beğenirsen, kanalıma abone olursan Deniz
Hocan'ı desteklemiş olursun. İyi ki
varsın. Seviliyorsun. Bunu unutma. Bir
sonraki günde görüşmek üzere. Hoşça kal.
this, you know,